on the eve of the New Hampshire primary
which is tonight Donald Trump did a
rally in New Hampshire and it was really
something to behold now we're going to
go through some of the the key moments
and for me at this point
you know the wacky part is less about
what Trump says although obviously Trump
is wacky and saying absolutely
ridiculous things it's more about the
supporters at this point who just nod
and clap along with whatever Donald
Trump says this rally was the epitome of
what I would call Trump culture where
facts don't matter
riling up a crowd with red meat that is
completely a dishonest if not factually
false is all that matters now to start
with as many of you know Donald Trump
has a very weird history about talking
about how he finds his daughter Ivanka
very attractive he's even said things
before like you know if she weren't my
daughter type of stuff and we've covered
that widely before and once again Donald
Trump talking about the beauty of his
daughter and he seems to recognize here
because he says I'm not supposed to say
that he seems to recognize that this is
something that is a little weird to be
saying again yesterday talking about
Ivanka and now clearly referencing the
fact that he said weird things about her
in the past take a look
also a woman that not too many people
know very powerful very smart very
beautiful even though I'm not allowed to
say that because she's my daughter
Ivanka
Trump then went as weird as that was
into his normal attacks on the media
claiming that they never show the crowd
at his rallies they only show his face
what's hilarious is as he started to say
that they were showing the crowd and
they continued to show the crowd during
this portion of the speech
they don't even like showing the crowd
they always show my face they never show
the crowd but you know what the people
can hear the crowd the people can hear
the crowd they know
the crowd of course visible at the start
and at the end of that 25 second clip
during which Trump says they never show
the crowd at my rallies and the crowd of
course just loves it and of course
that's more of the firing up of his base
against the media which unfortunately
has led to so much hostility against the
concept of a free press more than any
president in recent history Donald Trump
has really catalyzed in coalesced a
hatred if not disdain for media in the
United States under the guise often fake
news and we know the memes that he's
used Trump then goes on to talk about
how undocumented immigrants have no
addresses which is of course a strange
thing to say but more importantly he
seems confused between undocumented
immigrants and homeless people we have
video remember of Donald Trump being
confused between health insurance and
life insurance
that's a funny and depressing one we
have videos of Trump being confused
about many different things in this
video Trump seems confused about the
difference between an undocumented
immigrant and a person who is homeless
and then of course he throws in the
normal dehumanizing language that he
uses about immigrants record numbers
that we've ended catch-and-release you
know catchy releases you catch an
illegal alien by law you then take his
name and I just don't have addresses
what's your address what they don't have
addresses they come into the country
they don't have addresses so you take
his name Trump then raises the lie that
he simply won't stop telling which is
that in 2016 buses full of Massachusetts
voters were sent up to New Hampshire to
vote illegally and that's the only
reason why Hillary Clinton ultimately
defeated Trump by 0.3% there it's not
because she really won it's because
Massachusetts voters voted illegally in
New Hampshire now of course there's no
evidence whatsoever for that claim but
if you're watching watch his audience
start to nod with Donald Trump about the
hundreds of busses of Massachusetts
voters sent up to vote illegally and if
you're listening you'll of course hear
the booing and the
audio of his supporters immediately just
falling for this hook line and sinker
because you know you have some pretty
strange election laws here right
remember last time we won the primary
tremendously we should have won the
election but that buses being shipped up
from Massachusetts hundreds and hundreds
of
and it was very very close even though
they did but this year we you know you
have a great governor look at how little
the truth is worth that Donald Trump
casually lies about hundreds of busses
understand what you hundreds of busses
right
aside from there being no evidence of
this a lot of these polling places in
New Hampshire are tiny they would be
completely overwhelmed and paralyzed by
even ten busses showing up
never mind hundreds of buses being sent
up to New Hampshire but the crowd
doesn't care they clap and they boo and
they nod along to the lies that Donald
Trump tells and then again riling up the
crowd towards possible violence Donald
Trump pulls this entire thing about
we're going to protect your guns they
are going to take all of your guns and
all of your money and all of your stuff
take a look
we're going to protect you second
amendments by the way they're going to
take away everything they're gonna take
away your wealth they're gonna take away
your guns they're gonna take away
everything
the cult of trumpism it's very dangerous
we wonder how do people believe this
stuff a guy himself potentially not
mentally well so easily is able to get a
stadium full of people to believe what
he says or even if they doubt it to
rationalize him saying it and this is
how cults work truly I mean more and
more it went when you look there are
more and more cult experts that are
looking at the cult of trumpism and it
is reminiscent in so many ways of the
you know the cult leader who says April
21st will be the rapture we will either
be struck down here on earth or ascends
to a life in eternity in heaven or
whatever and then April 21st comes and
goes and they rationalize it away with
trumpets either well the Democrats
ruined it or the fake news media ruined
it or Trump was using it as a metaphor
he didn't literally mean or whatever the
case may be it is scary stuff and this
is why I am afraid of violence I'm sort
of afraid of violence no matter what
happens in November of 2020 but of
course if Donald Trump ultimately loses
and claims that it was rigged I am very
worried about the real-world violence
that these folks are potentially going
to do let me know your thought on that
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll take a
quick break and be back after this I
want to encourage everybody in my
audience to go subscribe to a YouTube
channel we're partnering with it's
called up flip they release new videos
every week in every video you meet a
different entrepreneur and get an
in-depth look at how their business
works and how they became successful
it's great if you like shows like shark
tank if you own your own business or
you're thinking of starting one the up
flip YouTube channel really does offer a
wealth of knowledge and inspiration as
an entrepreneur myself and a business
owner I've really been enjoying hearing
all of the different stories of the
people that they interview but it's
really fascinating content even if you
don't own your own business to go check
out the up flip youtube channel they're
friends of the David Pakman show I'd
love it if you would support them by
subscribing to their channel you can
find the up flip YouTube channel by
going to david pakman.com slash up flip
if you're watching this on youtube i've
put the link right underneath this video